what suggestions do you have for
screenwriters on developing a character
i think you need to know what your
character
needs to achieve in your broader story
and you also need to
think okay what would happen if i spent
time with this character
i always think of it that way so you
know anytime i'm writing a character
developing a character
i think okay if me and this character
went out to get a drink at a bar or
something what would we talk about
how would the conversation flow would he
be doing the talking would i be doing
the talking
you know would it be balanced not
balanced would they leave after five
minutes because they have something to
do
i always try to think of like the
broader world a character and habits
outside of just the script um just
because for me
i think that influences a lot of the
characters decisions and things that
they'll make later
in the script when i'm writing um and i
always when i develop
try to do kind of like a word cloud if
you will for a character
so i tried to think you know if you just
met this person for five minutes
at the grocery store never seen them
before what would your first couple
takeaways be so i always try to like
list those off
and then i think okay what would maybe
their mom say about them someone who's
known them forever and ever so i have
these like two different word bubbles
and it's always like about like
balancing you know what is their
kind of quick takeaways from a quick
appearance versus like the deep down
stuff that they don't let out so
that's really cool is that something
from a book that you got or you just
came up
it might be from a book i i just kind of
have done it recently in the last couple
of years um
i don't think i could call it my own
formula but
um it seems to work for me and it's kind
of a fun way to
role play a little bit with a character
to think okay what would they do
you know how would they do things um in
a different way
versus just like you know this person is
mad all the time because and you know
this person is happy because you know
it kind of is you're able to live in the
world and world build a little further
that way
at least just internally as a writer
that would actually make a cool app it
would be kind of cool you just
put someone's photo and then it
populates it gives you like
take you know two minutes and then it
populates yeah what someone's mom would
say about them and then what someone
would say
about them at the grocery store i like
the thought of a time limit on it
because then it just it forces you to be
very like rapid fire
with quick takeaways yeah i love that
you